[Music]
yes
yes happy
happy happy Thursday everyone no stop it
stop it
stop it put your clothes back on
so the Fallout from the train derailment
in East Palestine Ohio is just getting
started and like Joy behar's face it's
looking worse and worse by the day
it's shaping up to be a classic Biden
era disaster toxic preventable and
completely off the rails
although in that family a controlled
burn is what Hunter feels when he pees
they're erupted as Citizens vented their
anger about their health concerns over
the handling of the derailed toxic train
which had the media asking really
important questions like why aren't they
wearing masks and did they get their
boosters
even their mayor was ripping into the
train company like Anna Navarro into a
bag of malamars roll it
everybody's concerned I'm concerned he
spoke with Norfolk Southern I speak with
him every day they've been working with
us tremendously but they should because
they're the ones that screwed this up no
one knocked on my door I lived 50 feet
from the police station why didn't
Sirens go
come on
now
so where's our top leaders in all this
well President Biden spoke about
railroad projects in Ohio on Wednesday
but ignored the situation in Ohio what a
mistake that's like him giving a speech
on Alzheimer's while not wearing any
pants
meanwhile we know Transportation
secretary mayor Pete has been slow to
react but who knows he's still grappling
with postpartum depression
this guy's as useless as on Rachel
Levine
[Applause]
since they were built by white
construction workers
but he did tweet about it of course
blaming Trump conveniently forgetting
he's been Secretary of Transportation
since 2021 something the rest of us wish
we could do too
seriously this guy is the most famous
Transportation secretary ever and why
because he sucks harder than Brian
stelter on a duck fat Slurpee
[Applause]
which brings me to tonight's thought
experiment no keep your clothes on
audience
for now anyway
because it's time to play
Greg's reverse or opposite parallel
whatever Universe day
doesn't even try anymore so what if all
this were happening under a republican
Administration how would the media react
roll its van
this in some ways is worse than
Watergate it's worse than 9 11. in
effect a second kind of Civil War worse
than Watergate a second Civil War
that's a phrase that should frighten you
well it would if we were as stupid as
you
he's from CNN so what can you say
imagine that place under a righty
president
this is how the apocalypse starts yeah
it's not gonna be zombies it's gonna be
Republicans and they're damn trains if
Biden were president he would never ride
a train yeah I mean clearly Donald Trump
derailed those trains using his
telekinesis Powers if Elon Musk hadn't
bought Twitter those trains would still
be on their tracks and now Earth's got
about three weeks left so thanks GOP
foreign
and of course the Democrats they would
lose their
and that's hard for them to do because
they're full of so much of it that's
better I can already hear their screams
AOC would say that's more toxic than a
man holding a door open for me
Adam Shipp will say it's all a plan by
Trump to send smoke signals to Putin and
yes I have proof of that
and Liz Warren would say how
and of course Stormy Daniels would say
the mushroom cloud reminds me of
something but I can't remember what
one of our celebs how would they react
we're not just the worst thing it's just
the worst thing because it hurts so many
people what's going on here this is it's
it's wrong and this is no laughing
matter has absolutely terrified me we
don't matter we don't matter so when
that stuff happens I do in fact go
absolutely berserk anyway enough
but now it's under Joe Biden what do you
hear crickets and not the ones they
snack on at CNN you heard nothing really
until local news posted Clips on Twitter
and people started to take notice
without that would we even have known
this is another kind of controlled burn
the media trying to destroy evidence
that the administration's screwing up on
a daily basis it's like the balloons
without all those citizens sharing
videos of them flying over their
neighborhoods would Biden have even
responded thanks to cell phones
Eyewitness News has literally become
that and how about the scourge of
fentanyl without local news and citizens
piping up about it after two years Joe
finally mentions its name fentanyl
unfortunately he was trying to say donut
how about the homeless crisis at the
Chicago airport maybe if they were
wiping their asses with classified
documents but otherwise no one cares and
how frustrating for those homeless
people to be that close to escaping
Chicago
what about school boards green lighting
certain curriculums that no sane parent
would ever approve of again in all these
cases it's the locals that get the
national attention while the Lefty
leaders in charge consistently
downplayed the bad over and over again
but who knows maybe one day they'll stop
passing the buck and step up and take
responsibility yeah and on that same day
they'll ask me to host the Oscars
here he is
let's welcome tonight's guests he's got
a face for radio and a mind for a psych
ward comedian and co-host of the Jim
Norton and Sam Roberts show on SiriusXM
Jim Norton
when it comes to business she's got more
Scoops than the Raisin Bran Factory
you're a post on the money reporter
Lydia moyni ahead
people say she's down to Earth because
she sleeps in a cave Fox News
contributor cat too
and finally he uses a crane as a back
scratcher my massive sidekick in the NWA
World Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
Jim uh welcome to the show great to see
you and it's great to see you Greg only
successful friend I have oh well you
know what I was going to talk about your
successes of over a decade of local
reporting for the KTTV Reno station
you've covered a lot of disasters yes I
did I covered the Corleone wedding yes
you remember when Fredo had a meltdown
with his wife yeah I was the first guy
on that scoop yes how when you're
looking at how the media is covering
this does it disturb you as much as it
disturbs me they're doing a bang-up job
I think they really are like people will
address it and they'll go well yes we
did hear that that happened and we'll
get to it yeah it's like a zombie
apocalypse you know there's an explosion
they just nothing happened and then two
days later everybody's biting each
other's nuts and slow walking
are you looking forward to that yes I am
yes yes I am I've actually started
already on my own
good for you Jim that makes me happy
Lydia you are a business reporter or so
you claim this town is getting royally
screwed right I mean they're like you
know they just came out of covid what's
going to happen to their real estate
values and everything I mean you can't I
can't do anybody buy homes by Three Mile
Island
I don't know I haven't heard a lot about
home sales uh in that region recently I
have some time can you go look that up
yeah let me just do that right now uh
does everyone mind pause it no it's so
alarming because the fundamental role of
government is to protect citizens and
our leaders are so focused on ancillary
things like equity and infrastructure I
don't even know what that is and they
can't do the basics and so I think this
whole scenario has just underscored how
screwed up our priorities are we have
300 million dollars to put illegal
immigrants in hotels in Midtown
Manhattan but we don't have a million
dollars to put somebody in a hotel in
Ohio I I would imagine that the hotels
in Ohio are a little cheaper than a
skyscraper in Manhattan and you think
about other disasters Katrina you had
FEMA you had the National Guard we gave
people credit cards to make sure that
they could afford the basics we're doing
nothing here right we're just leaving
the mayor who's not equipped to deal
with the situation to try and figure
figure it out it's it's so sad too
because I mean you hear these ads and it
struck me recently about Camp Lejeune
you might be entitled to compensation
you think how could we let that happen
to people where they would be exposed to
toxic chemicals that's exactly what's
happening right here
and nobody seems to care and uh thank
you for mentioning one of our
advertisers
yes so uh
uh cat lady makes a good point in the
sense that you know the government
really is our catastrophic insurance
plan it's like if they can't do this
what's what what use do we have for them
at all
that's what I've been saying yeah you
don't even want it for the catastrophic
insurance well I
this is just so bad I mean like it's so
absurd I mean there's no way any of
these people are okay yeah and the only
reason that maybe any of them are okay
is because I guess they're all in it
together so they're like talking to
their friends like hey like how is your
radioactive Wasteland day going I'm like
are you kidding me with this I I like I
don't understand how it can even be
something where it's like okay well this
is because Trump's it doesn't matter
whose fault it is uh I mean like there's
animals that are dying because of this I
was crying today because some woman said
her cat died and if that were jeans I
would not be here right now no you
wouldn't I would not be here right now I
would be at the White House you would go
you would go total John Wick I would be
for a cat I I wouldn't be 12 years old
it has a its own cardiac doctor he he
does have a cardiologist I highly
recommend I can highly recommend one if
anyone's in need uh but like truly I
mean it okay and what's what does that
say for the other mammals aka the humans
that are living there can't be good for
your health or like you said home values
are your future I mean I like just it's
so bad it's just so bad you should be
the so bad chords come on and say that
is so bad yes I don't know how anybody
has any other reaction to this then like
I just all consuming are oh my God are
you okay
crazy Tyrus did you I don't know did you
know I hate to bring this up because you
might not do you know that they filmed a
movie about a chemical spill in this
town no yes it's called Uh White Noise
it was it's on I think it's on Netflix
and even the citizens how did it end I
don't know we should watch it yeah
that's probably how this is gonna end
yes no you know what's the connection to
Norfolk Southern I think so I think
that's they were doing Secret promotion
here yeah this is serious marketing
break a few eggs right because
Administration so we break a few eggs
you know so they'll be fine you know
they're not gonna see the effects right
away it'll take about 10 to 15 years
before the cancers come in and stuff and
by that time it'll be on somebody else's
watch I think the the the sad tragedy of
this is that the the railroad
was more important than the people and
that's what our government which is
funny because it's a democratic which
their whole Spiel is for they're about
the little guy yeah well the little guy
got punched in the mouth but it was the
little guy that probably voted for Trump
so they you know they the railroad came
in and sent their own specialist in I
love that that's the best thing to do is
have your own people go in and test the
grounds and the waters but they can't
hide the dead fish they can't hide the
dead birds they can't hide all the other
stuff but again they've tested it they
tested at least three houses so far so
it's it's all good
what they were the the furthest houses
from the incident but they're tested
that area is good you know and they'll
and we we laugh because they get away
but this is what they do with lower
middle class and middle class
neighborhoods and their argument would
be like well their value of their homes
is irrelevant they don't care about the
stuff the bottom line is the railroad's
still going the CFO but is covered and
they'll move on to something else
unfortunately except for got to take my
hat off and even though I work here
Fox is the only one that's actually
keeping the story going because everyone
else is ready to move on
foreign
and I'd like to say I'd like to say
you're welcome yeah what was that sound
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else